hello the new European Commission is an
office since yesterday in 10 days from
now the new European Commission will
present the European Green Deal
and if our common goal is to be a
climate neutral continent in 2050 in the
European Union we have to act now we
have to implement the policies now
because it is a generational transition
we have to go through three thoughts
three pillars for three minutes
the European Green Deal is Europe's
new growth strategy it will cut
emissions while also creating jobs and
improving our quality of life for that
we need investment investment and
research in innovation and green
technologies to pull this off we will
deliver a sustainable Europe investment
plan which will support 1 trillion euros
of investment over the next decade if
necessary if there is carbon leakage we
will have to think about a carbon board
attacks second thought only what get
gets measured gets done therefore next
March we will propose the first ever
European climate law to make the
transition to climate neutrality
irreversible this will include extending
emission trading to all relevant sectors
co2 has to have a price as the
secretary-general set it will include
clean affordable and secure energy the
boosting of our circular economy a farm
to fork strategy and bio diversity
strategy
if some are talking about the costs we
should always keep in mind how much more
it will cost us if we do not act now so
I thought this transition must work for
all or it will not work at all with a
just transition fund put forward by the
European Commission we will make sure
that we help those who will have to take
a bigger step and leave no one behind
the fund will leverage public and
private money including with the help of
the European Investment Bank that has
committed itself to become Europe's
climate bank in some ways Europeans are
ready if we move together we will also
move faster and this is in everybody's
interest we will be as ambitious as we
can throughout the cup negotiations we
are ready to contribute with our
European Green Deal to the global Green
Deal today's presenter musalla de la
palabra my premium he studies